est ce qu'on a vu elie kakou
s'embrouiller avec gad elmaleh car il le
confond avec un journaliste oui dit oui
oui oui oui regardez
et banalisent la rue maintenant je sois
jouer cette apathie
chercher les journalistes
[Rires]
non
il n'ya pas venir
[Musique]
mais bien journalistes vous allez
craquer le journal
avait une carte de presse selon
autour de 30 euros
émile essayait de trouver
de revoir et les gâteaux qu'on a
tellement aimé mais pourquoi qu'est ce
que vous faisiez la fête je pense qu'il
ya plusieurs choses déjà j'ai
l'impression de voir mon fils je me
voilà j'attends de voir mon fiston noël
à 20 ans j'ai 21 ans il ya une deuxième
chose que je voudrais raconter c'est que
cette séquence lâche en train de jouer
le mec mal à l'aise tous les soirs elie
kakou prenez un vrai passants dans la
rue et il sortait du point virgule il
ouvrait la porte comme ça ils prenaient
un gars ou une femme au hasard comme ça
il dit et tu veux tu rien d le spectacle
d'elie kakou et là ils filmaient et ce
soir là ils se sont dit si jamais si
jamais ça tombe sur un mec bizarre ouais
une femme bizarre quelqu'un qui veut pas
jouer le jeu mon film le dvd de la fin
la vhs à l'époque d une île on vous dit
est ce que tu veux bien jouer le gars
qui est un peu dépassée c'est votre
première fois donc là je fais une grande
performance d'acteur je joue le mec
embarrassé et voilà donc mais c'est très
touchant de revoir ces images parce que
j'ai adoré ce moment là de ma vie où les
cas qu a été la première personne connue
que j'ai connu je connaissais pas de
gens connus et le premier mac connu que
j'ai connu c'est elie kakou et qui était
visiblement quelqu'un de formidable
vitalité retrouvée avec lui après je
travaillais pour elie kakou j'étais son
poursuiteur j'étais technicien c'est le
premier il avait une petite voiture et
j'étais avec lui en voiture et j'étais
super heureux c'est la première fois je
voyais des gens à un feu rouge qui
klaxonnaient pour faire coucou un
méconnu et moi je me montre ici avec le
gars connu avec le maître connu quoi
hein c'est beau c'est super
autre question est ce qu'on a déjà vu le
corps d'athlète de gad elmaleh ces mules
email par un débardeur effet dit oui la
noël je dois ici si oui on est d'accord
très franchement ouais je sais je pense
pas vous pensez pas ba prenait et si la
croatie
[Musique]
alors ça va falloir m'expliquer
plusieurs choses dans cette vidéo il ya
plein de jeunes s'accrochent à expliquer
pourquoi pourquoi on sauve un faux crâne
ouais pourquoi un faux crâne ce qu'elle
filme sa à la taille à pattaya c'est
pour pattaya bien des batailles à le
film de franck gastambide et est bon
comme vous le voyez je suis fan de danse
contemporaine jeunes et moi c'est moi je
trouve franchement alors que
le mouvement des champs de saint charles
où il est il est terrible non mais
franchement je trouve que vous avez
vraiment voilà enfin on va dire que je
suis fan de gamme mais je trouve que
voilà on dirait un vrai dans ce super
bien passé lanceur qui a mangé beaucoup
de
petits le petit machin là le petit pic
atteint en fait vous vouliez
d'enseignants non pas du tout non mais
mime en revanche oui mais on n'est pas à
nîmes ouais voilà mes grands problèmes
de communication
[Rires]
d'accor bon autres autre petite question
des pas vu est ce qu'on a vu gad faire
de l'ombre de l'ombre à francis huster
au cours florent
non non c'était la star de francis
huster c'était vraiment une icône une
légende de conflans c'est le prof c'est
que le blaireau y aura des rois
raison
regarde jamais enseigné la bonne guerre
j'aimerais d'ailleurs c'est une
expérience unique en france et une
première dans l'histoire des écoles
d'art dramatique c'est un enseignement à
la carte on lui apprend à maîtriser
l'art dramatique pendant deux ans
beaucoup de comédiens connus sorte de
cette classe libre comme anne brochet
maruschka detmers ou yvan attal prochain
concours d'entrée en novembre prochain
[Applaudissements]
qui te font plaisir la plupart des
images en télé je les ai déjà vus celle
là je les ai jamais je les ai jamais je
suis vraiment alors bravo
c'était en 1993 93 93 et un reportage
qui était à la base un reportage sur
francis huster parce qu'évidemment comme
tu l'as dit il est proche il était
professeur et voilà et oh tu étais donc
en cours libre c'est ça dans la classe
libre en fête la classe libre c'est une
espèce de bourse en fait tu passes un
concours pour y être j'étais super
heureux parce que j'avais économisé de
l'argent pour payer mon année scolaire
et j'ai eu la gratuité scolaire donc
j'ai pu manger des pizzas avec 1,9 au
milieu
le truc et j'ai une pensée pour françois
florent qui nous a quittés cette année
il ya quelques quelques mois et pour son
fils xavier et tous les profs de florent
que je salue qui sont mes potes que
j'adore voilà c'était déjà c'était ta
vocation c'est est ce que tu voulais
faire absolument ouais j'en rêvais mais
vraiment j'en rêvais et françois florent
le jour du concours de la classe libre
il était n'était très près comme ça tu
l'as vu une forme d'autorité de distance
de et je te promets il m'a dit un truc
que je retiendrai toute ma vie et qui
m'a boosté une petite flamme qui m'a mis
dans le coeur et dans la tête j'ai fait
mon audition et j'ai voulu partir m'a
dit je nomme je dis oui m'a dit
j'aimerais vous voir briller un jour
dans cette maison cette phrase là je me
suis dit je suis passé j'ai un truc à le
coup au coeur callaway j'ai une
expérience mystique quoi film a dit un
truc et et voilà j'espère que quand on
croise des gens comme ça qu'ils portent
après on se sent justement porte et on
se dit je suis légitime je peux y aller
ma vocation ça donne confiance en fait
moi il m'a donné confiance in my mama il
m'a donné confiance quoi
enfin franchement c'est super dernière
dernière petit n'y avait pas vu très
très très vite est ce qu'on a vu gars de
se présenter aux municipales en belgique
il ya eu tout un suivi ici dans cette
émission est évidemment sur ce plateau
puisqu'il est venu mais en fait non
elle fait le ping pong a déclaré
absolument pas on l'a pas vu mais en
fait ce à quoi tu souris
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pour garder ce nom fait un saut n'a pas
un sosie
on à peu près loin sa présence et voilà
voilà le truc le plus drôle que j'ai vu
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est cette
photo avec les grilles gad elmaleh
[Rires]
juste pour quand même pour 10 de nom de
ce monsieur je peux d'el hamid ben
bakura et rencontre un gros stade je les
rencontre et ici cyril l'a fait venir
est ce que je ne savais pas c'est qu'ils
étaient logés dans le même hôtel que moi
donc en rentrant on a croisé mon
société blizzard vous avez surtout si
vous aviez sont ensemble il me semble
oui on a chanté ensemble il me semble et
non c'est vraiment un très bon souvenir
mais jamais tout engagement politique
non non non non non même temps un plan
local même non pas du tout d'accord pas
du tout départementales régionales
non non rien non milieu de la culture
n'ont pas mis la culture peut-être plus
tard un jour diriger un endroit qui fait
de la création qui se bougent pour créer
des jeunes en ont pas mis seulement un
théâtre pourquoi pas un théâtre géré par
l'état je sais pas on combat et demi et
il va aller inventer rassemblés ont créé
un festival un festival